I do not I'm out of here
get me out of here got the day of the
wedding after that whole thing just
moment happened I still haven't seen
that yet
I only know you know what I lived
through but after that you know I really
just realized this is like an amazing
person and he was just speaking his
truth and I stood up for what I believed
didn't he stood up for he believed in
and we decided to give it another go and
we've been together ever since and it's
just been this crazy wild ride honestly
I didn't know I was gonna say I don't so
it's it's really crazy to say but inside
we eat everything that was seen on a
camera and everything that's been seen
to the world isn't everything that
happened so we had a lot of you know
behind the scenes beautiful moments
where we enjoyed our time together we
had fun we stayed up laughing late at
night we watched movies we did go ride
scooters through you know Lana like we
had our fun date moments and when we
were together we just we loved it and he
flashed really well like everything
worked and sometimes I feel like the
pressure of you know TV your cameras
relatedly to people that have never done
it before you can crash under pressure
and the idea of being able to give
excited fall in love with her I did
still love her I didn't want it in at
the wedding I just I didn't want either
of us to really feel locked down or
because we had a have a wedding that I
had to determine where we went from it
yeah we don't want this show to
determine what we felt because of this
experience we wanted to just really give
it a true chance without all of that
added pressure on
let's talk apparently that's the one
thing that we can't do so right now
we're going to talk please sit
we had our challenges it wasn't easy
right leg off the show I mean we still
had our fights we still had our blow ups
and the biggest thing was is do we want
to make this work are we in it because
we run a show together arena because we
love each other and this is like what we
really want and I think we both we sat
down when you had to talk about we said
you know we do care about each other
we're gonna have these challenges it's
it's not gonna be easy but it'll be
worth it and we we fought we argued we
laughed we've cried we've we went on
trips together and we find out like
overall we make it would make a pretty
great team so it has been so exciting so
scary so overwhelming and all the
different forms and surprisingly just
like everyone's just been so nice so
nice and like we are just so grateful
for that we know that you know maybe
that might not last forever but I I love
that everyone has seen this experience
for what it is and they relate to damia
they relate to me and in moments that
I'm like wow like really like you chose
that moment like I did not like that
moment and I'm really happy that like
helped you or that you like that let's
come on to the show
we both had you know past relationships
or other cases things that didn't work
out and I think we got to the point our
live like this probably isn't gonna work
I mean when I came on here I was like
this probably isn't gonna work I'm not
gonna blind date and meet somebody but
it boggled my mind I was sitting there
like oh I should want to do this like
they called me back again am I actually
gonna go on the show and it and it was a
drunk on the truss where they were gonna
show it but they actually found me on
tinder they on Instagram so I didn't
apply for this they found me on tinder
or mattress girls like finally I met
somebody cute and then this girl had
made one ice cream she's like I'm
actually casting for the show so and
people were like I can't believe like
you're on tinder and let me hear
everybody's tired of swiping everybody's
tired of looking like you want somebody
you can have a real connection with in
this show did that it allowed us to take
out all that after the show I think the
show for me at least caused so many self
revelations right like this is your life
this is how you know we respond to
things like let's do some soul-searching
here and I realized my soul was that in
that anymore and I actually went through
like a good amount of jobs but it was
good because each one taught me
something different and I was just able
to finally just never gave up good never
gave up sets her mind to something that
is one thing I will give her as she goes
forward and she will she'll stay with it
so I see you as my equal and I'm just as
strong as you so I want to ask you
Damian Powers will you marry me I will
marry you it's definitely an experience
that you don't know how you're gonna
react until you're there I didn't know
that I was gonna fall in love with him
in a pod while talking through someone
through a wall like I didn't know that
that was gonna happen in the first place
and then I had these you know these
really real emotions I want to be with
this person for the rest of my life
because the connection was just so and
that's something that they just didn't
show enough of he I felt like he was
reading my mind through a wall and it
was just this very surreal experience
and so I wanted to spend the rest of my
life with him I mean I'm with him now so
obviously that's something that I I
couldn't you know shake off with the
pressure or anything but it's something
that you know we can all show our our
true emotions and what we want the other
person to see but it really comes down
to you know how are you gonna take me
in every single situation and I always
related you know my actual life to what
was going on in this really crazy
experience you know if I'm having a bad
day one day I like
how are you gonna you know support me
are you gonna think that I'm someone
that's just like - of a dramatic turn
all these things and he won me over
every single time and it was just life
condensed so think about being in a
relationship with someone for years
and have it all come down to one month
of trials tribulations beautiful moments
and just like unforgettable things that
will stay with you forever